all right welcome welcome to the webinar
we're going to talk about midsection
weight and cortisol so the first thing I
want to cover is that the weight in your
midsection is very very different than
other types of fat around your body so
what you were dealing with is it's a
type of hormonal fat and it's coming
from a hormone called cortisol there is
another hormone involved it's called
insulin but we're going to talk about
that on the fourth seminar so this
seminar is all about cortisol and the
effects that it creates on your body I'm
going to be using this reference book
CIPA encyclopedia of endocrinology by
Frank knitter and we're going to give
you a lot of data it's a very
interesting subject especially if you
want to get rid of your belly fat so
without further ado let's get started
I'm going to turn on my screen saver to
show you see we could yeah okay good so
you can pretty much see that alright so
what I want to talk about is some what
is this cortisol thing okay the purpose
of cortisol is to adapt adapt the body
to stress for survival purposes so the
purpose of the body is to survive but
your adrenals tend to change the
different functions to handle the
environmental stress okay that's really
what it does and if you're being chased
by a tiger you can imagine you got pulse
rate blood pressure blood to your
muscles you have oxygen opening up in
your lungs you have your your mental
acuity is very very aware of everything
you have more blood flow to the heart
all these things are stressed States so
that would be one of the purposes
cortisol but I know a lot of people want
to get rid of their course all because
it's creating the belly fat
but really you need this thing for
survival of mechanisms so we don't want
it to be too low and we don't want it to
be too high because there's just as many
problems with low cholesterol as there
are high cholesterol okay and if you
have people that have symptoms of high
cholesterol and low cholesterol mixed
you know you try to do research on that
and you won't really find too much data
and I have my theories because you have
these people that present with like for
example belly fat but they're showing
symptoms of a low cortisol not a high
cortisol why is that like they might
have allergies or a high blood pressure
where they might have inflammation or
itching or acid reflux well I think
what's really happening is that cortisol
is too high in the beginning and then it
tries to connect to a receptor like an
indifferent like all these hormones
connect to different body parts and they
cut they plug into these little tiny
receptors kind of like a like
information goes into your ear well if
that cortisol that stress hormone is too
high it will cause the receptor to adapt
and downgrade very similar to insulin
being resistant because there's too much
insulin and your body just adapts and it
just won't it blocks the insulin so so I
think you have this thing called
cortisol resistance it's the only thing
that makes sense so when you have a
situation when you have high levels of
stress over a period of time sustained
stress all these receptors downgrade and
now we have symptoms of high cortisol
and symptoms of low cortisol not a good
situation so the course all is produced
from a gland on top of your kidney
there's two of them and they're little
tiny glands that sit on top of the
kidney right in the central part of your
body and these glands take a beating
they're rugged they basically are going
to send messages through the body to
handle the amount of stress so it keeps
the body alive now the interesting thing
about the adrenal is that it has two
arts and inside and outside the outside
is just all gland tissue and that's
where cortisol is made but the inside of
the gland is all nerve tissue is it
weird isn't it so it's part of the
nervous system that's called the
autonomic nervous system it's just a new
word the orb you know it's kind of like
the system that works on automatic you
don't think about it we call autonomic
you can call automatic but it's called
autonomic nervous system and and that's
the part of the nervous system inside
the adrenal that makes neurotransmitters
now what is the neurotransmitter it's
like a hormone that travels through the
nervous system so here we have hormones
that travel through the blood and
they're just communication particles
that travel through the blood but then
you have communications that travel
through the nervous system so you have
two ways that the adrenal can
communicate through the nerves in the
blood so it really innervates every
single part of your body there is a
device that can measure the autonomic
nervous system and you can get clues on
what's going on to the inside of the
adrenal and I have that device and I'm
going to talk about it in a second but I
want to explain this autonomic nervous
system thing okay
it's really simple its purpose is to
help balance the inside of the body all
the different functions and keep it on
regulated properly so it adapts to the
environment to keep the inside of the
body at a Curt a certain constant state
they call that homeostasis where your
body is trying to balance itself out so
you have like all these things that
speed up and turn on and then you have
all these parts of the body that can
turn off and one part of the system of
the autonomic nervous system is called
the sympathetic division that's that's
all the flight-or-fight that would be
like if you're being chased by a tiger
you're getting stressed all those
reactions
come out of this autonomic nervous
system like its electrical circuits that
come out of your if you look at the
words locate it's located in your middle
back of the spinal column so that's
where all those wires come out and cause
different reactions that turn on but
look it over here we have the opposite
division the off switch we call that
call that the parasympathetic division
and that turns things off and look where
that comes out of that comes out of the
top of the neck we're going to come back
to this so just remember the on switches
are on the mid-back and off switches in
the top of the neck okay but there's one
less thing and I know it's hard to see
this so there there's a little
connection of this on switch to the
adrenal gland right here but if we look
over here on the off switches there is
no connection to the adrenal with the
off switch so the adrenal doesn't have
an off switch which explains a lot it
this explains why people can't turn off
so you have people that are under
sustained stress for many years and they
get maybe they retire and they where
they go on vacation or they go to bed at
night and they try to go to sleep and
their body will not shut off so the
accumulation of stress builds up and it
can get stuck in the body and it can
cause you to be on 24/7 especially with
your head it's just going going going
going going it can't you're not thinking
solving problems so the nature of the
adrenal is survival so what that's going
to do is put you in a survival mode
where you're always solving problems
your attention is on bringing problems
up solving them constantly and when it
gets even it gets to the extreme where
you find that your body gets stuck in
that you you lose your tolerance for
stress so things start to get to you
especially anything that's the opposite
of survival
like the opposite of lot being logical
competent same order so you'll have a
low tolerance to any incompetency out of
order situation slope you just won't
have the patience and that's one of the
symptoms that of adrenal overload
because the person can feel subjectively
that they're very highly critical and
that's not their personality that's just
the adrenals affecting their personality
I mean how many relationships are
affected by having the adrenal overload
where the person just is just like back
and forth back and forth no patients I
mean it can get so bad you're in a room
and the clock is ticking and you just
can't stand that I mean it's like they
have to go to sleep with up with the TV
white noise to kind of filter out stuff
but they're multitaskers they're
thinking all the time and so that's one
of the problems with the adrenal is that
it can create a cognitive effect that is
very undesirable
okay so let's um let's go back to the
slides I'm going to show you this right
here all right so so does that make
sense we have the autonomic nervous
system we have the part of the autonomic
nervous system that turns things on it's
called sympathetic and then you have the
other part that don't they call that
rest and digest that's called the
parasympathetic set and it's there's no
parasympathetic connection to that
adrenal so there is no off switch
fascinating okay so let's talk about can
the adrenal glands or let's just say
this can we measure a part of the
adrenal gland generally speaking to see
what's going on yes you can there's a
technology out there called heart rate
variability and I don't want to get into
the technological aspects of this but
it's basically a fancy test that
measures the that part of the nervous
system and
two things one is stress states and it
measures a cumulative stress and it also
measures recovery or that that turn off
switch so it measures the on switch in
the off switch
okay now the on switch or the
flight-or-fight is this long I'll right
here it should be normally straight up
and down plumb not to stress not to
burnt down and then the off switch or
the recovery mechanism should always be
twice as high because you need a buffer
if you are being chased by a tiger in
the wilderness you need some reserve to
get away you can't just be right on the
edge because there also you would stand
up and pass out so you need a good nice
robust recovery mechanism to handle
stress now let's show you something when
you have this tall now let's say the
tall that is too high remember it should
be straight up and down this person is
pretty jacked up on inside of their body
and they're revved up um they're
stressed out but look at this person
might not feel too bad because their
recovery dial is so high that's the all
the brake pads so they're all gas pedal
but they have good brakes to handle it
so this person is an abstain of they're
not burnt out but they're burning out so
just a matter of time before it burns
out okay so they're going to have
problem sleeping and excessive thinking
that type of thing now if we get down
over here we have that not too bad with
the tall dial okay so there may be a
little bit of flair to fight but look at
this recovery it's way way down here so
this person is really not doing good
because recovery is necessary for
metabolism for sleep for handling stress
and for the heart to handle exercise so
this person should not be exercising any
high intensity because they're going to
feel dizzy they might have
stress on the heart I take them a long
time to recover and there's this
recovery is an active recovery so it's
going to prevent them from getting into
the deep sleep they're going to be very
not very tolerant to stress so I just
wanted to kind of show you what these
two mean because you can kind of
visualize not just subjectively feeling
stress but you can see the stress
accumulated stress so both of these
people here if you go into their history
I always ask two vital questions that
you should always focus on if you have
any problems you want to solve your
problem is find out like when did you
start having this problem when did you
start gaining weight in this section
what happened just before that there
will always always be something that
triggered it and you know sometimes you
ask the doctor and they'll go oh no you
know I know you started having
projectile vomiting when I gave you
those medications but that couldn't be
it I mean it's the only obvious thing
you took the medication you vomited okay
so this is like the obvious thing what
happened right before it and you're
going to get clues as to your adrenal
stress your belly fat um I mean I had
one lady um and she has these itching in
her body almost like a yeast infection
and I said when did you get that she
told me it was like a I think was like
three weeks ago I said what did you do
just before that and she just she
couldn't think of anything and so I just
told her I just started asking her said
well did you have antibiotics she goes
no I said did you take any nutritional
yeast she goes oh my gosh yes I did
I said ding-ding-ding so because
sometimes when you get the wrong type of
nutritional yeast which is a supplement
for people it can create some yeast
issues if you take too much okay so
anyway that's just an example of of you
know finding out what caused
something is okay so now the next thing
we talk about is stress stress is a
little bit different for a lot of people
um but typically people get stressed out
from physical stress injury surgery a
change of environment change of diet um
being in a bad marriage being in a
better having a bad job but out of all
the stresses that I that I observe
people go through I think the biggest
thing that I see is stress with other
people once you agree so we can pretty
much just take people and put them in
two boxes number one the people that
bring you up and number two the people
that bring you down okay um the people
that you're around and they stress you
out and you're connected to them you're
going to have to either improve the
situation or not be around them because
all day long I'm constantly trying to
help people change their environment and
it just boils down to being in this this
situation where they're around this
person who is it could even be a family
member but what's happening is that this
family member is being so destructive
that's killing this person but they
don't want to not be around because
they're family and blah blah blah so I
want to just explain one personality
type that I think you could identify
with it's called the passive-aggressive
this is the person that told you they
stood up for you but they actually
ruined your reputation
they they will say to you like a nice
comment like hey I like your hair was it
did you get it at cheap cuts you know
your haircut a cheap
really I would never say that or that's
a nice jacket was that on sale like it's
just a little bit of a kind of a
destructive comment so they're very
degrading but they're doing it in a nice
way and they'll smile at you as they say
are you feeling okay you look a little
bit tired I had this person say to me
once some hey congratulations you
graduated from Chiropractic College hey
why don't you want to become a real
doctor so that's just interesting it's
just something that you probably
wouldn't say but it's a very destructive
I was in a seminar one day and had all
these people said in here and this lady
raises her hand and she just smiles at
me and she says dr. Berg um we love you
but how do we know that you're not a
real quack I'm like what that is so rude
um first of all how do we like who's we
we as you everyone wants to be there so
sometimes people are very very um
destructive
covertly and those are the people that
you need to avoid like the plague they
will mess with your adrenals guaranteed
okay now I talked a little bit about
tolerance for stress but as the Drina
glands get weaker and weaker you lose
your patience you lose your tolerance
you fly off the handle easily you don't
tolerate slow people on the freeway you
don't tolerate um incompetent people
that make mistakes you walk in a room
you'll find that thing that's just not
quite right your your attention goes on
it Moore's because your body at your
mind is fixated on problems 24/7 so even
if you had a wonderful day your
attention will go to that one thing that
wasn't quite right so it's hard to be
happy because your attention is just so
stuck in these issues so that's just an
example of
an adrenal issue and if we measure that
on that graph that dial the low dial
would be all the way to the left okay so
there's a lot of effects of cortisol
that I want to talk about because I mean
this virtually blows my mind how many
issues can occur from the adrenal so I'm
going to read from you this in this book
called Sivir this encyclopedia on
endocrine system medical illustrations
by Frank knitters and MD this is enough
pretty much all the medical schools um
but check it can cause belly fat
diabetes muscle atrophy in fact let me
just show you a page page 84 right in
this book and I'm just gonna I have my
book it's hard to read this but I will
send you the slides um but here's the
thing you have a problem with high
cholesterol the adrenals are very
destructive on protein so it'll break
down your muscle protein your collagen
and it will turn that into fat you can
pretty much see it on this graph you see
this lady with these skinny legs in the
big belly
well the adrenals will start taking you
proteins from the thigh muscle and
converting them into sugar and then fat
into the belly because the body is in
the state where it thinks is starving
regardless of the all-you-can-eat buffet
down the street it just thinks it's
starting and then after it depletes this
little go after the butt muscles and
turn that into belly it's very
destructive so proteins collagen joints
fall apart high cholesterol cholesterol
will go high because cholesterol is
needed to build adrenal hormones low
vitamin D levels Wow
immune system the white blood cell which
protects you against infections are all
controlled by the adrenal that's why
they give adrenal hormones in the form
of cortisone or hydrocortisone or
steroids or prednisone
for pretty much all really bad
infections so if you look at what
conditions someone would take prednisone
or a steroid or cortisol 4 you can get
an idea of the function of cortisol it's
an anti-inflammatory they give it to
allergies heart conditions coronary
problems immune problems and the big one
autoimmune problems we'll get into that
in a little bit but on this page in the
bottom it talks about viruses coming out
of remission with it with high levels of
cortisol I mean it's it just blows my
mind how many issues that people have
and it's really they're treating all
these separately they're not going after
the root issue
yeah allergies asthma inflammation
arthritis bursitis tendinitis excessive
brain activity acid reflux
diabetes hypoglycemia other than that it
won't it doesn't affect anything I'm
being sarcastic poor wound healing
Buffalo Hump in the background face red
cheeks it's rosacea moonface belly fat
high blood pressure insomnia sleep apnea
oh my gosh it goes on and on and on okay
so those are all the symptoms of the
adrenal craving for salt chocolate and
even sugar so the adrenal gland has a
lot of effects and a lot of people have
a few of the effects but not all of them
because it starts off small and it might
gradually get more and more more so when
you go to the doctor they rarely check
for cortisol and the problem is that if
you get one test that measures your
cortisol it doesn't really do you any
good because cortisol works on a
circadian wave through the day and night
you really to measure this correctly you
would have to measure it every four
hours throughout a 24-hour cycle to get
a better impression and I believe that
saliva is one of the good
is to do that but here's the thing when
they even if you test positive you would
have to have the majority of these
symptoms before someone does something
about it like the doctor and they only
use a drug on a compassionate basis so
really they don't have a solution okay
so now that's in this book right here
but there's some other things that I
want to show you because there's also a
condition called it's a low adrenal I
showed you all the symptoms for hygiene
or a member you could be a mix but check
this out
this person loses weight they get
atrophy they shrink and they get tanned
Dewayne you get tanked okay you might
like that right but it's a very
unhealthy state and you probably hear
people that go through stress and lose
weight that's not healthy but this
person has vertigo
that's an adrenal Michael Jackson mine
losing the pigment their immune system
is completely destroyed and they have a
lot of inflammation John F Kennedy had
this condition called Addison's which is
load renal and have to be injected by
with adrenal hormones so a lot of
autoimmune issues so the adrenals can
also affect bruising and male pattern
baldness facial hair I mean acne I mean
think about how many people have these
conditions and so it's it's huge so we
have this one gland that affects so many
issues and it's basically triggered by
stress so stress is a huge culprit in
destroying our lives in our health and
especially with weight loss a lot of
people on a diet and exercise well you
can get some changes with diet and
exercise but there's some other things
that you need to know about to help your
belly fat that go beyond diet and
exercise that very few people are
talking about we'll get into that
all right so I covered the effects of
cortisol okay stress accumulates
pregnancy hysterectomy tonsillectomy
infections see when you were a kid you
may had your tonsils out
you had respiratory infections you had
sore throats and now you're an adult and
you might think well that's probably
it's not an issue that was in the past
all that stuff does affect your adrenals
it's like you have this accumulative
number of applications on your desktop
computer like right here all these
applications on your desktop can slow
down the computer it's the exact same
thing with the adrenal it's the
accumulation of stress and a physical
mental emotional the people that I talk
to that have never really experienced
that much stress they always can lose
weight easily and they don't have a lot
of health problems it's an interesting
connection so personally I've had
probably more injuries and infections
then any patient that ever came my
office my whole life I had sore throats
council issues lung issues digestive
issues sleep issues arthritis
inflammation mg chronic fatigue issues
I've had fractures of my leg my arm my
elbow I've had Falls on the head
whiplashes motorcycle accidents
wrestling injuries and fractures
fractured my neck several times so all
that stress accumulates and that's what
drove me to figuring out some of this
stuff because I personally had a lot of
these problems
okay so visceral fat visceral fat is a
different type of fat it's the fat
around the organs
it's the fat around the liver it's not
superficial and it can be measured and
that's coming from cortisol
so so the question is how do you lower
cortisol you don't want to necessarily
you want to balance cortisol by lowering
the the impression that it left on the
body
cortisol well let me just get into that
in a second I wanted to touch on this
next slide here first and then I'll get
into what to do about it I don't we're
talking about autoimmune conditions a
lot of people have them lupus rheumatoid
MS you name it there's so many
autoimmune conditions and there's a lot
of theories out there and what causes
them well I'm going to tell you right
now my theory on this is that I think
that autoimmune diseases are related to
the adrenal and the reason I say that is
because you can take any autoimmune case
100% of them and ask them when did it
start and what happened just before that
and there is always some stress event
that occurred right before the
autoimmune condition whether a loss of a
loved one which by the way losses will
affect the adrenal a thousand times more
deadly than physical trauma divorce loss
of a loved one multiple losses I mean
the problem is everyone is around people
that eventually they're going to lose
all these people so eventually they're
going to have adrenal issues it's just a
matter of time I've been very lucky my
family very few people have died one
person very close to me my grandmother
but that's about it
but the point is that autoimmune cases
always have this huge stress usually a
loss right before it so that means that
the adrenal gland is involved okay so
what I want to show you next is there's
some data that I'm going to share with
you and this data is has to do with
another interesting finding with
autoimmune cases okay this is
research is but been done on this guy by
the name of Marshall called the Marshall
protocol and here's the here's the
simplicity of it he found that or not he
does he just observe this and he's
connecting the dots he found that the
vitamin D is heavily influenced with
auto immune and immunity so in other
words vitamin D is intimately connected
with your immune system and he found
that the vitamin D receptor is inside
the cell and the difference between
vitamin D and other vitamins is it's a
fat Seibel vitamin that in can go inside
the cell more than a water-soluble
vitamin so it goes deep down into the
DNA of a cell and what's fascinating is
that he found that the receptor for
vitamin D called vitamin D receptor vdr
gets blocked and then you can't absorb
vitamin D anymore
okay and then the person has this
Associated finding with autoimmune and
this is what he does he gives someone
the vitamin D receptor VD are analog
here's another word I want to explain
what it means I'll define it an analog
is something that kind of mimics
something so it acts like something so a
vdr analog would be something that could
help open up the receptor so it can it
can help mimic and open up the receptor
okay so what he found is that there's a
medication called benicar which is high
blood pressure medication that is a it's
it's a some type of remedy that helps
reverse the receptor problem that the
block receptor okay allowing vitamin D
to go in there and helping the
autoimmune system and I don't agree with
this because it's a drug and he also
uses heavy duty antibiotics for a long
creative time I think for like a year
so it's not from my viewpoint it's not a
good solution but what's interesting is
the vitamin D does get blocked so now
let's take that into this book right
here Frank neder page 84 right here
cortisol counters vitamin D levels it
blocks vitamin D I don't know if you can
see that so in other words the question
is why does vitamin D get blocked in the
first place
Marshall talks that it's a microbe that
does it and that's totally could be true
but what about the adrenal because it's
a stress the adrenal is the thing that
triggers the whole event because it's a
stress event now if you do a search on
the vitamin D receptor analogues and I
know I'm giving you some words here so
just hang in hang tight there is another
thing that I think is very natural that
can act to help open up this vitamin D
receptor and I stumbled on it and you
can use bile salts yeah from the gall
bladder purify bile salt do help open up
that vitamin D so you can absorb more
vitamin D at the receptor level which is
fascinating because that's where they
need to be doing research not been a car
because it's is too many side effects
and also my bio helps you break down the
fat side of a vitamin vitamin D helping
you your immune system so I just found
that kind of an interesting connection
and I want to bring that up if there's
anyone listening to pass autoimmune you
should research using bile in your diet
and vitamin D together to see if that
can help you on in addition to also
looking at what you can do to improve
the adrenal functional role I just want
to make make a disclaimer here that I'm
not claiming to cure any adrenal
diseases okay I'm not here to do that
all I'm here to do is give you the
information so you can do research
and you can know where to focus on and
get with your doctor to help yourself
okay so that's my disclaimer all right
so check this out you guys heard a
roundup roundup ready monsanto GMO right
it's a herbicide that they use on GMO to
be able to it's because GMO is like they
made it resistant to Roundup Ready and
herbicide so it's genetically modified
food well I just found in this
toxicology reports that there's Roundup
Ready creates a major problem to the
adrenal gland yeah interesting it
disrupts the endocrine system of the
adrenal gland in male rats of course I
don't know it could affect humans too
what do you think but I just want to
bring it up because in this stuff came
out in 1996 which is date coincidence to
a lot of people getting sick shortly
after that so I'm curious this could be
a huge connection to a lot of adrenal
issues from people consuming genetically
modified food without even knowing it
and that would be in all the soy and the
corn but also in the animal products
that eat the soy in the corn which is
huge it's all over the place okay so now
I'm going to talk about some tips to
reduce stress alright
because what we want to do is we want to
you know not take on just a pill to
lower core so we want to look at the
whole body we want to find out what to
eat of course we want to find some way
to deal with this issue and so there's a
couple things that you can do overall
because yes we want to correct the
problem but we also want to correct your
environment and so it doesn't keep going
on um so there are techniques that you
can extract stress from the body I'll
cover a few even injuries but what
happens with the adrenal is that it
creates a lot of situations
in your head a lot you're thinking
you're analyzing I mean who you are at
work in front of a computer right now
you're watching a computer and then you
go to bed but there's not a lot of space
going on so with stress what stress does
is it kind of it's it collapses your
space and that's why when you're
stressed you might even say I need some
space because you don't have space so
one of the remedies for stress is to get
space so hiding in space go outside go
hiking go in a park get lots of space go
to the beach all this is very
therapeutic you might say it's the salt
water you might say it's the Sun it's
the space that you need and so going to
a gym behind a treadmill looking at the
computer screen is very hurt bad um I'm
not against meditation but if you're
sitting there meditating focusing on
something and maybe your meditation is
something different but that's how I
some people that do it totally but and
it works for them but the point is that
if you were to extrovert your body and
not necessarily focus on any thing but
just observe things in your environment
you know temperature site sounds without
analyzing everything that would be very
therapeutic if you did it every single
day because all day long you're solving
problems with your work we have to
reverse that and extrovert your body or
your stress okay so that's one thing
with space another thing let's go back
to the screen share here more sleep now
some people have a problem sleeping I
had a problem sleeping really bad and so
one of the common remedies for helping
with the adrenal and stress is to get
more sleep so now let's talk about sleep
how do you fix sleep first of all sleep
there's several different causes to
sleep problems you can have
flashes for example you can have
problems with stress that you're
thinking and you can't wind down easily
your night out you have a problem where
you sleep for two hours and wake up at
2:00 or 3:00 in the morning and you're
laying there bright awake yet during the
day at 2:00 or 3:00 you're completely
exhausted okay because your circadian
waves your rhythms are off so what I
like to do is I like to make sure the
eating is right so there's nothing
interfering
I also recommend doing various
treatments either
go to a doctor that I trained come to my
office or if you're not avail to do it
to do a version of do yourself version
of this technique which is the neck you
pressure technique and I'm going to show
you a couple techniques I I do
acupressure on myself every night before
to sleep my practitioners work on me as
well of course all the injuries that add
right but there's a tool that I want to
show you a lot of you watching this have
this tool already
it's an acupressure tool it has three
widths so it's good for different body
shapes but I use the widest one we work
right back here so now what I'm going to
show you sleep that will really blow
your way okay let me see if I could find
the immature okay what I want to show
you is that remember when we showed you
at the beginning of the webinar the
sympathetics the on switch and then the
parasympathetic off switch
and the off switch basically is in the
brainstem up here in the top of the
nerves in the top of the neck right here
well the name of that nerve is called
the vagus nerve okay that's the name of
it and it comes from the Latin word
which means wandering because it travels
all the way up to you're up to your neck
down to your your organs let me just
quickly just go back over that because I
this
important I want to show you something
yeah right here you see this nerve
coming out it goes all the way to the
face the lungs the heart the stomach the
pancreas deliver the intestines goes all
into these organs right here right so
check this out
where am i hair okay so there is a
there's a treatment nowadays it's called
that actually it stimulates the vagus
nerve and it's called the vagus nerve
stimulation and I just wanna let you
know I disagree with this treatment and
I'll tell you why because it's sending
impulses into this nerve and there's a
lot of side effects if you if you use
this technique there's a much easier way
to stimulate the nerve without having to
send electricity some shockwave through
your nervous system but look at the FDA
even approved it for for um depression
and epilepsy but it's also used for
anxiety and stress and Alzheimer's and
migraines in fibromyalgia even obesity
why would it be used for obesity because
the vagus nerve is the turn off switch
it relaxes the body increases recovery
and it helps lower court to solve okay
tinnitus with ringing the ears look at
this atrial fibrillation autism bulimia
chronic heart failure hiccups coronary
heart disease why would it be used for
all these things because it can it can
organs it's like you have this circuit
that connects you organs so they're
using electrical stimulation to this but
here's what I use let me show you what
you can do and I didn't think a lot of
people realize what this is doing when
you do this technique they built entire
chiropractic techniques around adjusting
the first cervical vertebra in your neck
okay called a hole-in-one the Atlas y
because it creates such effects on the
rest of the body with relaxation so the
technique I develop I use my hands and I
get in there so but a lot of times if
I'm going to place where there's no one
to work on me that sucks so I built this
after my hand
I mean modeled after my hand it's the
exact width of my hand but look at how
big my thumb's are right I have huge
thumbs and that's why I made this really
thick so what I do is you put this in
the back of your couch or a tall back
chair and you kick back your feet and
you just lean back and you let this
thing connect right underneath your
skull and you let gravity pull you back
and you can push your head back and
relax guarantee if you did that for two
minutes you'd be probably ready for bed
why because it stimulates the vagus
nerve naturally it relaxes all the neck
muscles it helps the nervous system
which is the off switch this is turning
on the off switch which will then turn
off the cortisol because it will affect
that flight or fight mechanism so so yes
there are techniques out there to turn
off the on switch but this is like
triggering the off switch okay so we do
both we work on both now the other
technique I can't really do it here
because I do it in my bed
then I should create a video on that but
you use this on your back that middle
back part like from your upper back down
to the lower part you can use this
because you would use this part right
here to hit all the way down your spine
one and you just let gravity you lay
back on your bed and you work on that
that's what I do every single night and
I go to sleep right after that um my
wife's like are you always going to be
using that thing why don't you massage
my back right but I have to do my back
first right so that is something that a
lot of you already have but if you don't
have it I highly recommend you get one
um okay so now let me go back to my
slides here
okay so so I just wanted to show you
that there is a vagus nerve stimulation
thing I don't agree with it but that's
what they're doing now but there's all
these different techniques that you can
do you can work on the adrenal glands
you can work on the mid-back you can
work on the tissues in the front these
are all the points that I use to extract
stress from the body okay
and what am i doing is I'm using this to
put myself in the Delta wave sleep so
acupressure is a really good way to help
someone sleep to get better sleep to get
deeper sleep and turn the body off so
when you go to bed every part of your
body can finally turn off okay so we
talked about space we talked about sleep
let's talk about being too serious
okay there's a word I want to teach you
it's a French word which means
institutions this means carefree non
serious untroubled unworried okay let me
just so I can talk to you about this the
adrenal case is put you in a state where
you're solving problems 24 days you get
really really serious anytime you're
really serious you increase stress on
your body a good way to reduce that
would be to be very institution but I
would write that on some paper to put on
your refrigerator and be very carefree
about things go through the day and just
be light joking but not degrading but
just very very playful that viewpoint
and attitude is the best viewpoint to
reduce stress the people that have the
hardest time with losing weight are the
most serious people
they're like calling their calories and
they're stressed out and they're like
weighing herself I had one lady comes in
and she's freaking out cuz she's not
losing weight and she's trying
everything nothing's working and I can
see she's very serious about everything
so I said this is this is what I want
you to do I want you to promise me for
one week when I start I explained the
definition of the solution see carefree
I want you to do this for one freaking
week okay I want you to stop being so
damn serious I want you to stop weighing
yourself I want you to have fun I want
you not to care about your weight just
do the duck eating plan do the things I
say and don't worry about it 24/7 why
because all that worry is triggering the
adrenals adrenals think way too much
you're in their head and all that just
stirs up the Drina
24/7 so again we have to extract the
stress we have to have the attitude of
being in solution and carefree do
something getting involved in some games
games is a very great way to be in
solution to play folk don't watch the
news before bed watch money okay
something like that
so in soutien is a playful caring none I
mean carefree way to go about life then
the people that I know that are the most
successful are the most institution okay
so that's number three okay now we're
going to talk about potassium there's
another interesting little point here
all right so I've got my little book
right here page 84 as you know I this is
like a hobby for me
I love endocrinology that's all I study
24/7 weekend's I'm into it my wife's
like aren't you interest in any other
books like no she was one glad you're
interested in because I don't think
anyone else is but there is one thing on
this page that talks about potassium
deficiencies so with adrenal you lose
potassium not to mention you probably
don't get enough from your diet because
if you watch it in my videos you you
require 4700 milligrams of potassium
every single day
4700 one banana is 300 you need 12 bananas
or 11 bananas so here's the point that
I'm trying to make potassium is a
physiological tranquilizer it's a
calming thing of the nervous system
without potassium your nervous system
can't calm down and chill out it's a
thing that lowers the pulse rate and
even blood pressure if you're deficient
in potassium your pulse rate goes up try
to sleep with your pulse rate in the 90s
it doesn't work so it will help calm you
down
so what food is high in potassium
vegetables so there we can work back to
the big salad you need a lot of
potassium to calm those adrenals down so
you need huge salads twice a day lunch
and dinner
no fail just stick it in there sea
vegetables don't just have potassium
they have the vitamin C complex that you
need see most of the vitamin C in your
body is stored in the adrenals and most
vitamin C that people buy is synthetic
so you in ascorbic acid in high dosages
will create a vitamin C deficiency
because it's synthetic and it depletes
you of the good parts of the vitamin C
complex so what you need to get is a
food based vitamin C or just the food
itself if you eat that much vegetable
like maybe huge to huge salads a day or
plates the vegetable before you have the
protein you will have all the vitamin C
that you need another thing that vitamin
C deficiency is will she will show up is
pink bleeding gums loss of collagen so
we talked about in the seminar a
nutrient absorption we talked about
having an acid stomach to digest
collagen but now you need vitamin C to
build collagen so that's in the
vegetable family okay so we need a
potassium and we need the vitamin C um
potassium is in abaca dose so one
avocado is 800 so I have like probably
half an avocado every other day but I do
a lot of salads I go to the farmers
market I get my lettuce and I always cut
red cabbage and I stick a little kale in
there
I like the dinosaur kale and I will do
that every single day if I don't do that
I find my sleep is not as good as it
should be okay now when you eat a lot of
protein that stimulates your body but
you need the vegetables to counter the
body counter that that revved up protein
action all right
so now the next thing we're going to
talk about is b1 okay so b1 vitamin b1
is the magical vitamin for stress but
there's a couple of things you need to
know about it number one the more stress
that you go through the more be one that
you burn up b1 is necessary for your
nervous system if you're very deficient
in vitamin b1 you will have a condition
called berry berry and I'm just typing
this up right now so you can so I can
just show you the actual name of this of
this condition that affects the psyche
we see yeah look at this when you're
when you're deficient berry berry you
get this condition we have neurological
and psychiatric symptoms yeah depression
severe anxiety doom and gloom Wow
yeah so if you ever want to see all the
symptoms you can look up berry berry but
um you can look at that up later but
here's the thing be one most the time is
made synthetically so you have to find a
natural b1 now it's not it's very
expensive to make I like to get my b1 in
nutritional yeast the problem is most
nutritional yeast is made synthetically
it's enriched synthetically with b1 so
you need to get an enriched yeast that's
not has this enriched with synthetics
and there is one product that I do have
it's the adrenal de formula okay and I
have in here a natural b1 but I also
have the entire vitamin C complex that
the adrenal needs and all the minerals
that the adrenal needs and several
herbal things with the adrenal needs but
this is interesting because when you
take this within I would say about five
minutes maybe less you're going to feel
like just the stress this kind of goes
right away this is a great thing to take
if you have that nervous tension
build-up that you're going to explode if
you have people around you that have
that just look one of those in their
coffee and they'll just be so nice to
you so the people that are hyper
critical the people that are have low
tolerance to stress take three of these
take nine of these a day but I think
three would be fine sprout to the day of
it taken as needed and you'll feel it
change because it affects the nervous
system it pulls stress out you know it's
weird it's like sometimes when I when I
don't take it for like a week I'll feel
like a little buildup of stress and then
I'll just take it because I I run my
body and I do all sorts of exercise
stressful things and so I'm burn up b1
all the time but b1 naturally comes from
wheat grain but not the type of grain
that you get from the grocery store if
you were to grind your grain and eat the
grain right away
it might be a problem for your weight
but it has all the big complexes be one
so I don't need grains so I need to get
my grains from something so the adrenal
de formula is the stress formula for the
adrenal it has the b1 in there it has
all to be complex and it comes from the
type of nutritional use that's
unfortified and it doesn't have the the
yeast effect that will cause a yeast
infection so it's a really good stress
relieving product that helps with stress
and energy and focus and also nightmares
when your deficient and B one you get
nightmares and heavy vivid dreaming
so that would be indication that you
need that as well okay so b1 is very
very necessary for any type of stress
events or stress symptoms or any
psychiatric problem and they should be
giving b1 um you know they label people
with a DD and attention deficits order
and schizophrenia and bipolar it's just
it's just a lot of its b1 deficiency and
adrenal stress that's what it is okay um
now there's the one that I use for sleep
and I use this I developed this formula
for myself I take one before bed
sometimes I'll take two rarely but you
just need one before bed adrenal my
formula
this formula has been changed many many
times and I perfected it to the point
where you get the optimum wonderful
sleep where you just turn off go to
sleep for seven hours when you wake up
feel refreshed you don't feel groggy but
it really helps people sleep it's a very
popular thing so I take one of these and
I take three of these through the day
it's a great combination if you want to
find something that helps you naturally
sleep but this is not treating cortisol
this is supporting a healthy dream and
it helps you sleep - the whole night so
you can rejuvenate so this the effects
that you get from the sleep help
rejuvenate cortisol
but this helps you sleep okay so that's
the combination that I would recommend
all right so now let me go back to this
for a second
alright so there's a book that comes
with this massage tool that shows you
all of the different techniques that you
can use but also if you even go to this
my website dr. Berg calm for / massage -
tool - manual you can watch the videos
on how to do the technique you need the
device but at least you could see that
the technique and you can probably do a
few of them to help yourself tonight
when you're going to sleep for today
okay so here are some different things
we talked about the turn off switch the
vagus nerve now we're going to talk
about your eating plan now in previous
seminars I've talked about ketosis um
ketosis is your body's burning fat but
the problem is if you're an adrenal type
there's some problems with ketosis
because the problem with the adrenal is
that adrenal puts your body in the state
of making new sugar it'll basically
convert your protein to your sugar the
name of that is called gluconeogenesis
which is basically sugar new making of
making new sugar that's what it means so
with doing an eating plan with the
adrenal you have to make sure you have
enough protein if your body is breaking
down protein if you go on a low protein
diet or a vegetarian diet with adrenal
your body will have a tendency to eat up
your own proteins and that's where you
see collagen loss you'll see your legs
get thinner your muscles get weaker so
we always need to make sure that we have
at least some protein with each
okay the next thing that the adrenal
case needs is or what doesn't need is
they need zero sugars they cannot do
sugar why because your body's already
making too much sugar as it is and so we
got to put them in a state where there's
no sugar we've talked about that in the
ketosis webinar it's X zero sugar a good
amount of protein and plenty and plenty
of high potassium food that's the
vegetables okay now here's the thing
that I'm going to talk about in the
problem with ketosis of the meal plan is
this
you know ketosis allows you to have a
lot of fat the problem if you're an
adrenal tight and your metabolism is
slow is that when you check the urine
you may be in fat burning no doubt but
the fact that you're burning is not the
fat in your body it's the fat that
you're eating it's the dietary fat that
is what we don't want to be burning
necessarily in high quantities because
we want to strength your body so with
adrenal cases they can do a modified
ketosis diet but they have to increase a
lot more vegetables with potassium keep
the sugars down but the amount of fat
that they can eat is somewhere between
moderate and low okay not extremely low
but they can't get away with high
amounts of you know fatty things because
they just need to be able to burn their
own fat and so that is the twist on that
ketosis diet so I like to start out with
a little more fat and then slowly
decrease it until you're burning your
own fat and you will know that when
you're on the scale if you do the key to
ptosis diet and you're purely in ketosis
and you're not losing any weight do we
know you're just burning the fat that
you're eating you might not be gaining
weight but we want you to lose weight
okay so that's just a clarification on
the adrenal eating plan now the other
point I want to make on is the Paleo
diet paleo that's really good but for
adrenal cases
I found that you can't do the fruit and
the berry and it's a little bit
restrictive but listen you may have 20
or 30 pounds to lose in your belly or
ten pounds of fat or maybe five pounds
it's a different type of fat it's not
going to come off with traditional
balanced diets and I'm going to say
something that kind of goes against my
philosophy and I think it doesn't really
go against it but it might a little bit
you know I talk about good healthy lose
weight not lose weight to get healthy on
some of the adrenal cases you can't have
a so-called healthy diet where it can be
healthy but it's the traditionally
thought of as healthy see people think
of healthy diets is oh you can do fruits
and berries and whole grains none in a
row the type of eating plan that you
need for the adrenal would be some fat
just a little bit lower okay
not low fat between moderate and low you
need high potassium foods you need a
moderate amount of protein not too much
and you want to make sure you have zero
sugars that's that's the diet that will
help you but you're going to have to
also pull out this stress now I have a
chart here and I'm going to you look at
the bottom of this video you'll see a
link for these slides you can kind of
study this and you can have all these
lines but here's the diet that I
recommend for the adrenal now this is
the kale shake I change the recipe for
the kale shake I'm no longer
recommending berries if you're in dream
but if you have a high metabolism or or
let's say you have a male body and
you're 30 years old you could probably
do fruit you can do paleo you can do
higher fat you will still lose weight
but I'm not talking about those people
I'm talking about the menopausal woman
that is struggling they need to be a
little bit stripped on this so I'm going
to explain what you should be eating
the kale is just a way to get the cow on
your body
we used to recommend putting a
combination of a handful of kale and
berries in water now I'm recommending
put the kale on there put the stevia
berry flavored liquid stevia ok it'll
taste like berries it's kind of sweet
and you can drink it down to shake if
you want to get if you want to drink
your um your salad ok for breakfast it
you must have a protein breakfast a
protein and some fat whether it's a
little steak some eggs a little cheese
avocado chunks maybe a burger patty
here's an avocado and an egg these are
all really good breakfast foods and if
you consume the protein for breakfast it
will stabilize your blood sugars in the
evening one of the triggers for cortisol
is a low blood sugar hypoglycemia
so just by if you skip breakfast or you
eat the wrong thing for breakfast you're
going to trigger Cora salt in the
evening so I'm showing you what you
should do to keep the cortisol level in
check for lunch we do the big salad we
do a little bit of protein fish shrimp
seafood chicken don't worry about taking
the skin off we're not worried about low
fat okay for dinner
do the same thing do some vegetable dish
with some protein if you're not hungry
don't eat because within 48 hours - -
one week - possibly a little long it in
one week if you do this then you're
limiting the sugars your body will start
to convert its enzymes its machinery for
burning fat so it takes a while to get
into fat burning ok but it will burn fat
and you won't be as hungry and you won't
crave as much ok now is a little snack
in the evening you could do a little
hummus with cucumbers or celery a little
cheese a little bit of nuts don't go
crazy with the nuts
I think people eat way too many nuts and
too much peanut butter as a snack
because it does have a little bit of
carb
and then we got the celery with the
peanutbutter little cheese and this is a
keto bomb I have these recipes on my
website but those are some things that
you can do to keep it really really
simple a couple points with the keto
bombs they're really delicious they're
very filling they're very fattening only
take them as needed so don't try to eat
the whole thing and that's why you want
to make them in small batches so you
don't have them sitting around but there
they don't have any sugar so but if you
do this you won't crave sugar your sugar
cravings will go away very fast okay so
that is what you're going to be eating
okay so we have the adrenal night
formula in the day formula on my
webinars I always give people a discount
if they want to get the kit so either
adrenal kit and I'm going to show you
right now um you see if I could find it
right here okay so this is the adrenal
stress kit it has the adrenal day
formula pulls the stress out this is the
Drina night formula take one before bed
take three during the day some people
need six at least and it comes with the
massage tool a book how to use this in
videos but it's not the actual DVDs it's
online digital videos a link that you
could watch to use this is it so don't
look for a DVD and this kit is a certain
cost on my website I gave you the
maximum discount from this webinar so
you get 20% off if you want to get it
some of you already have the massage
tool okay so in that case what you can
do is you
can let me just give you another thing
here called adrenal kit which is just
the night formula and the adrenal day
formula ok so because if you already
have the massage tool you know maybe
just this is what you need right here so
I will also give you 20% of this so what
you do is you can click this button and
use and it automatically goes to the to
the shopping cart with the coupon code
already there so 20% is the highest
discount that I've ever given am only
giving up the webinar so I don't know
how long it's going to be active for but
definitely take advantage for it now
because it's going to be helping you
save money and also help your adrenals
and what I also will leave you with a
coupon code if you happen to miss the
link whatever I have these this coupon
code that you can type in to my website
for the adrenal kit
Padrino kit is just these two things
right here and then the distress kit is
the adrenal kit with the massage tool
okay and that's the code right here and
you go to dr. Berg comm and then click
shop enter the code in there and I will
also list the codes down below on this
webinar if you happen to miss this but I
want to thank you for watching this
webinar and I hope you enjoy the
information on the adrenal and I've
gotten some valuable tips to help your
stress and lower your belly fat we
talked about a lot of different things
and the effects of cortisol so I want to
thank you and I hope to see you in the
next webinar have a wonderful
evening or day and wherever you are on
the planet and I will see you in the
next webinar